I know that the idea is that
you know tonight today was Eid and
you know maybe we could skip the
class tonight but honestly ly I get
depressed when we don't have class. Even
if nobody is going to sit here and
listen, I got to I got to talk. I got to
teach. My blood pressure goes up when we
don't have class. My sugar starts going
all crazy. I got to teach. So, whoever
wants to listen, you know,
alhamdulillah,
who whoever needs to leave or wants
to leave, that's fine as well. But
you know a lot of times I'm teaching
it's mostly for me. So we are going to
continue inshallah tala what we set out
to do during Ramadan that we weren't
able to finish due to the amount of
detail that we
that we explored in the book of fasting
of alwajis.
However,
we have gotten through a good half of
it. So I'd to complete that
portion that we have left inshallah
before exploring other
parts of
this very important book and its
subjects. So we will continue in the
book of fasting. I mean Ramadan is over.
Yes. However, fasting is not over and
Ramadan is already on its way again. So,
in one way, yes, we did finish Ramadan
yesterday, but another way of looking at
it is Ramadan is one day closer again.
So it's always good to keep ourselves
prepared and to have this knowledge in
order to be able to worship Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala upon knowledge and
see that's really the difference then
isn't it the difference between
knowledge and imitation
what is imitation
so our prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam tells us
that
two types of people in their graves
in the narration of Albbaz
two types of people one type of person
when he is placed in his grave and it is
covered
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will
restore for him his hearing enough to be
able to hear the footsteps steps of
those who just buried him as they leave
leave him there at the graveyard
and then two angels will come to him in
they are named
and they will sit him up and they will
ask him three questions
who is your lord meaning who did you
worship truly
And what is your religion? Meaning what
was your way of life? How did you
worship Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala?
And who is your prophet?
And the believer will answer saying
and at that moment a voice will sound
will call out and
[Silence]
And so then a voice will call out, "My
servant is true. He is correct. He is
dutiful.
He is
correct in what he says and what he
claims."
And so
expand his grave for him and furnish it
with the furnishings of paradise and
clothe him with the clothing of paradise
and open for him a window to paradise.
And in other narrations, the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam added
that
it will be opened to him a window to the
hellfire
and he will be shown this was to be your
place.
This was supposed to be your place
had
you not answered with what you just
answered.
And then a window would be opened to
paradise and he will be shown his place
in paradise. And at that moment he will
make dua. Oh Allah,
oh Allah please hasten
the commencement of the hour. Let me get
to that.
He says,
He said, "And as for the hypocrite
or the
fed, the disbeliever,
the majorly disobedient
that this person when asked
who is your Lord?"
He will say,
H in the Arabic language and alif this
is used to articulate
to articulate something that is on
the tip of your tongue but you just
can't quite remember it. It's in
English when we say right
and so he will say
Listen very closely. This is the point
here of this narration.
He says that the hypocrite
when asked these same questions. Now
really the question that we need to ask
ourselves is
is this person answering those questions
at that moment.
So what I mean by that is is this an
intellectual answer? Is it something
that is gauged based on your
intelligence or your strength of memory
that if you're really smart and you're
really clever
and
you are very keen you will be able to
answer. But if you have a bad memory or
if you are unintelligent you would not
be able to answer. Is that where the
answers to these questions come from?
Where do the answers to these three
questions come from? Imagine this. A
test. your entire life. All of it. The
whole story. Every smile, every tear,
every frown,
every heartbreak,
every
pain of pain,
and every
feeling of joy.
All of it,
every thought
was all leading up to these three
answers.
That's what it was all about. These
three answers. Seems simple, right?
And so the question is, will we be
answering those questions
in the grave?
When do we answer those questions?
Who could tell us when we will answer
those questions? Really?
[Arabic recitation]
in this life. Correct. Right now, we're
answering those questions. When you're
put in your grave, you are going to take
your life's work
and you are going to summarize it in a
nutshell into three statements.
That's it.
Right now, I'm answering those three
questions.
Right now, you're answering those three
questions. Yesterday, you were answering
those questions. This morning, this
evening, tomorrow, you will be answering
those questions. If Allah has written
further life for you, this is where we
answer those questions.
Right?
But in the grave, we will summarize
those answers
in these three statements as Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
he says subhanahua
that
He says, "Subhan,
read your book, your book of deeds.
You are enough of a witness to bear
against yourself or for yourself."
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
The human being is watching him his own
self. He knows even if he gives all the
excuses in the world. At the end of the
day, the raw truth, we all know. We all
know what we're guilty of and we all
know what we are innocent of. And so
when you're put in the grave, you answer
these questions and this is the
commencement of the rest of eternity,
whatever it is.
So the hypocrite
and listen very closely to how the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam defines
how he defines hypocrisy here.
Hypocrisy in the Quran in its most true
form is disbelief in the heart but an
expression of belief in action or on the
on the body outwardly. Right?
But
hypocrisy is not just one stage or
level. There is a gradation of
hypocrisy.
There are those who are believers with
zero hypocrisy and there are those who
are hypocrites with zero belief and
between them are many many many shades.
And so
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam defines
for us hypocrisy here. He says that when
the hypocrite is asked these questions,
who is your lord? Who did you worship?
Who is your prophet? What is your
religion? He will say
I don't know.
I heard people saying things and I said
what they said.
Notice the
notice the
definition of hypocrisy here.
That hypocrisy is had they been born in
a Christian country amongst Christians
they would have said whatever they said
and had they been born amongst magians
fire worshippers they would have they
would have been magians and had they
been born amongst Hindus they would have
been Hindus and had they been brought up
by an atheist family or society they
would have been atheists They
religion, spirituality, the Allah, who
am I, where am I from, where am I going,
who do I belong to, what is my purpose?
These are moot points to these kinds of
people. They're unimportant.
It's minuscule little thing of life.
It's a little quirk of life. It's not
really important at the end of the day.
That's that kind of person. And so that
kind of person when they're placed in
their grave, they will say,"I
heard people saying things and I said
whatever they said."
And the opposite will be their response
than the believer.
A voice will sound from above and
my slave
is wrong. He has lied.
And it will be said, "So, furnish his
grave for him from the fire, and clothe
him from the fire, and open a door to
the fire for him." And exactly the
opposite, a door or a window to paradise
will be opened and he will be told this
was going to be your place in paradise.
You see it? This was supposed to be
yours,
but you refused.
And that will then be closed and another
window will be opened and he will be
told this is instead your place in the
hellfire.
And at that moment, he will beg Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala to delay the the
hour. I'd rather be in this fire in my
grave than be in that.
And so the point here that the scholars
have taken from this narration and other
narrations it
is that the real true difference between
knowledge and imitation
is not just to repeat other people's
conclusions.
I heard people saying things so I said
them. Now does that mean in every single
detail of Islam in your life in my life
we will never
we will always know the evidence from
the Quran and Sunnah and always
understand the conclusions of the
scholars? No. There's not enough time in
anyone's life for that. Few men and
women on this earth have ever been able
to reach that level of knowledge.
However, not all knowledge is the same.
And it starts with that which you have
between yourself and Allah directly.
When you stand to pray,
why are you praying this?
Do I know that this is how my prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam taught me to
pray?
When I say this is right,
do I know that from Allah and his
messenger? When I deem this to be wrong,
messenger?
This is the difference between knowledge
and imitation. There will always be a
level of in our lives. We have to follow
our scholars. We have to because not all
of us are able or even most of us.
However, all of us is able to know what
Allah said with respect to the most
intimate details of our worship of
Allah. That's easy. Allah sent to us a
book that is what?
It is clear and clarifying. It's not
it's not something that
needs to be translated and is in need
of other people to explain to us those
meanings of the Quran which are most
clear. Bread is halal. Water is halal.
Zena is haram. Ribba is haram. Shik is
the following. Is the following. These
are things that translated into any
language anyone can understand.
And so if you look at human beings, you
notice that most of what most people
claim and say,
they are just repeating other people's
ideas. They don't know these things for
a fact. right now
if I were to say the earth is round,
would anyone disagree with me?
Who amongst us here can prove this?
Most of us cannot. I cannot.
Right? However, if someone came and told
us something to the contrary, we would
laugh them out the room. Correct?
this level of insistence that this is
right and this is wrong without evidence
this is the ultimate enemy of knowledge
because what is knowledge knowledge is
knowing Allah
knowing his messenger
and knowing the religion of Islam
with evidence evidence
with the evidences of that.
And this is the difference between
knowledge and ignorance or knowledge and
imitation. And this is what we attempt
to do. We attempt to learn those
evidences from the Quran and Sunnah. If
we are able to understand them, great.
If something occurs to where we're
unable to understand the evidence then
we have the conclusions of our scholars.
Having said that inshallah we will
continue on tomorrow morning after
fud the classes will resume starting
tomorrow morning and also after isa each
night except for Monday and Tuesday. We
want to keep our momentum going from
from Ramadan. And so inshallah
with that we will end we'll make the
salah and makeaw is that what we're
doing.
We've been saying that for a whole
month.